speaking of non-candidates Ron DeSantis
from Florida we know that he's adopted a
lot of Donald Trump's mannerisms in
speaking including this accordion hands
thing that Donald Trump does very often
he also now seems to be copying how
Donald Trump says China this is like
really really weird China yeah
um there's a video that was much
publicized yesterday
of Ron DeSantis taking questions at a
digital Bill of Rights event and he
seems to be copying Trump's
pronunciation of China take a listen to
this
so that's that's there you also have the
role of China
oh what a weird what a weird Society
we're in huh let's let's take it from
the top
so that's that's there you also have the
role of China in Tech uh with things
like like Tick Tock and this is
something there if you look at the tick
tock that they use in China China it's
much different than what they're trying
to do in the United States with China
it's all China by the way it's really
funny hearing scientists talk about
technology descendants talk about
technology and foreign policy he sounds
genuinely clueless a very uh wholesome
patriotic uh in the United States
they're trying to inject as much garbage
into this as possible yeah isn't that
bizarre like this is not the biggest
issue but it is very strange very very
strange and Trump has a long history of
uh saying China in a really odd way
let's say China China
China China China China China China
China
[Music]
[Applause]
you go over to China China China China
China China China China China
so anyway I'm thinking that this might
be really funny until we realize it kind
of isn't and the world is crumbling
again but for the time being
this is an insane Republican primary it
hasn't even really started and it's
crazy Donald Trump already attacking Ron
DeSantis slash meatball Ron going after
Nikki Haley in new ways which we we will
talk about a little bit later uh we have
Ron DeSantis mirroring Trump but not yet
announcing even though he's leading
Trump in some polls while not being a
candidate Nikki Haley announces early
she's only running against Trump right
now and yet she can draw not a single
distinction between herself and Donald
Trump it's February not of 2024 of 2023
so this is going to be a Bonkers primary
and if nothing else I'm glad you'll all
be here with me to observe it all uh we
will have these clips that I played for
you
on our Instagram you can find that by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show we're going to take a very quick
break Neil Valley will join me after the
break maybe not a name you know but a
guest requested by many of our viewers
and listeners it will be a fascinating
conversation and then we'll be back with
more of the events of the last 24 hours
we'll listen to a voicemail or two much
taking place today on the show glad
you're with us
it's a new year many of us are trying to
make new positive changes here's
something really simple that could be a
game changer our sponsor athletic greens
every day I take a scoop of ag-1 I get
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
Whole Food sourced ingredients to last
me all day long this way I just know my
nutritional bases are covered for the
entire day it has everything I want and
that's important to me rather than doing
the individual supplements and vitamins
or whatever
I don't want to do any of that okay ag1
is the simplest way to just get
everything I want for my nutritional
Foundation each day ag1 is also a great
bang for your buck you're going to end
up spending way more on all those
bottles of vitamins and supplements and
minerals so save some money make your
life easier just a scoop of ag1 I love
the travel packs which let me take ag1
wherever I go I have the big pack of
ag-1 at home and when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get
five free travel packs plus a free year
supply of vitamin D which I use during
the winter the link is down below